I'd like to take
a moment to defend Andy.
>> Thank you Ben.
>> Sure.
In his defense it's really easy to
justify storing your model in your view
because it's so easy to do.
For version one of Cat Clicker he
didn't set up anything special
to store his data.
He just asked for the data out of the
view, updated it and put it right back.
But as we can see,
that did not scale very well when
his project got much bigger.
The biggest issue with Andy's code is
that he stored his data in the dom.
Or, more generally, he didn't separate
his view and his model within octopus.
In fact in his code, the model and
the view were the exact same thing.
And that's what got him into so
much trouble.